Here you see an incredible new robot
that learned to explore, stand up,
and even handle packages. And more. Now, wait a
second. What you see here should be impossible!
So, why is that? Why is this
impossible? Dear Fellow Scholars,
this is Two Minute Papers
with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Well, to understand what is going on here, let’s
look into the popular Large Language Models first.
You see, when training a large language model
to understand English and be a good assistant,
we can give it tons and tons of data from
the internet to learn on. For instance,
the early GPT-2 read Amazon reviews,
and learned to write new ones. This
was possible because tons and tons
of training data was available.
However, this should be impossible for a real
robot in the real world. Why is that? Well,
have a look at this paper, where scientists at
NVIDIA tried to teach a software agent to run.
And it kind of learned to run, okay, but after
quite a bit of training. At first, it looked
like this. Now letting a robot loose in the lab
while flailing around would not work too well,
because it would injure itself and its environment
before any meaningful learning could happen.
So in software there is plenty of training
data to learn from, but for robotics,
there is no data. None. Or even if there is,
there is just not enough to learn anything. So,
how can we solve this? Well, the solution is my
favorite. Which is learning inside a simulation.
Letting the robot play around in a video game.
Here, they are doing reinforcement learning,
which means truly playing a video game.
Here, you do something, and if you do well,
you get a score. A reward. If you don’t do so
well, you get nothing, or a negative score.
Now, we also need a little magic sauce here to
make sure that the robot is curious and wants
to explore and understand the world around
it. Normally, that is not that difficult,
for instance, DeepMind’s agents can play video
games as they are yearning for a high score,
so they will go around and explore. However,
there is a huge problem. A TV problem. Yes, you
heard it right. The AI has a TV problem. Agents
like these can encounter a TV in a virtual world,
and then, this happens. Yes, they get addicted
to it, and they never want to leave. Now that
is real human-like behavior if I’ve ever seen
one! This happens because the agent is getting
new information all the time and it’s much more
interesting than these otherwise boring levels.
So, how did they make this little robot
curious? Well, by engineering the rewards
of the game in a way that for instance, if
the angle or the velocity of the door changes,
it gets a reward. Thus, look! It
starts experimenting with it. Now,
new task! If we wish to get it to move
boxes around to where they belong,
we can craft a reward involving the velocity of
the box, and the distance from the container.
Now hold on to your papers Fellow Scholars,
because this is the moment of truth. Let’s
jump from the video game world into the real
world, and see how this little robot fares. And,
whoa! Look at that. It can navigate around
in the real world competently, it can even
stand up. It now opens those doors, and can
handle packages. Well, as you see, it handles
them at least as gently as some of the delivery
services out there. Another human-like trait.
Perfect! Now jokes aside, by further tailoring
these reward functions, I would imagine that it
could be made much gentler with these packages,
and even doors just one more paper down the line.
And also, bravo, what has been achieved
here is extremely hard. Why? Well,
because we cannot just make a simpler video
game for this robot to learn on. It has to be
good enough to even work in the real world
after all! And if the knowledge from here
does not translate properly to here, things can
break really quickly. This was an amazing feat.
And just imagine that now, we have better
and better tools to create virtual worlds,
a lot of our episodes are on new papers
that improve these potential simulation
environments. And every single one of
those could be one step closer for us
to have these little AIs train in these virtual
worlds, and then come out into the real world,
help us out and do all this safely. For instance,
these little robots could help us with last-mile
delivery. The idea behind this paper could
also help us create better self-driving
cars that can safely train in an environment
where we can make crazy hard levels for it,
and with a powerful computer, have it train for
years and years in computer simulation time,
not in real time, and then come out as a safe and
competent AI agent. What a time to be alive! And
this is not science fiction. Not at all. In an
earlier paper, we saw NVIDIA’s AI train for 33
years in simulation time to play Minecraft,
and boy, did it learn a great deal in there.
Now, this new work, of course does not
come without limitations. Hand-engineering
reward functions is a bit of a limitation here.
Which means that we have to write these rewards
ourselves. So, if we need it to perform a new
task, it needs a new reward function for that,
limiting the generality of the agent. An earlier
paper we talked about here could potentially
remedy that as it is about teaching these AI
agents to find out what a good score would be.